it wasn't a ceasefire it was a lull it
didn't last long I have been hiding
under my bed
for the past six hours
the area where I stay at the moment
has been shelled to shreds
I have heard nothing but explosions and
gunfire
and shelling
and screams
Roseanne Ahmed sends his voice notes and
this video she's a British national who
traveled to Khartoum for her cousin's
funeral now she's trapped there
I
and my family members are terrified to a
point where we have gone numb
as a British national
I haven't heard anything from the
British Embassy
my only question is
if there is no plan to get me out
please tell me why
one country did have a plan and has
already carried it out Saudi Arabia took
some of its citizens and other
foreigners to safety more than 150 of
them travel by land to the port of Sudan
and then by ship to Jeddah
the Sudanese Armed Forces said they were
coordinating efforts to evacuate foreign
citizens and diplomats from Sudan the
British prime minister chaired another
Cobra meeting today but the government
remained tight-lipped about any
evacuation plan saying only that it was
preparing a number of contingencies
much of the fighting has been centered
around the capital khartim as the
Sudanese armed forces and the
paramilitary rapid support forces battle
for key infrastructure
there's also been clashes outside the
capital in El fascia and Nyala cities in
the west and Ella bead south of the
capital
Djibouti airport is the key to getting
people out and countries have sent
planes there waiting for a safe time to
fly into Sudan
France flew in a plane last night and
the Sudanese authorities said they
expected the United States Britain Japan
and China to evacuate their diplomats
and Nationals by air with military
transport planes
foreigners might get a plane ride
Sudanese citizens though have no other
option but to flee over land West into
Chad
the unhcr says around 10 to 20 000
people are seeking Refuge there
as many belongings as they could so we
have seen people who are bringing the
beds bringing the blankets bringing food
and so whatever they could bring and
where yes a majority of women and
children like in most of these Villages
but there were also the men General
Abdel fatal burhan commander of the
Sudanese armed forces and the country's
de facto leader said that both sides
needed to sit together his most
conciliatory statement so far
but even as he spoke the lull was ending
the battle for Khartoum resuming and
people bracing For Worse to come
Cheshire Sky News